watch yourself around rihanna now  rihanna i don't know if you know  i don't know if you know how criminal  you are okay let's just look at this  picture did you ask permission from the  club when you left holding this class  absolutely  did you ask about that glass  that looks  i'll just speed it up what about this  one what about this one did you ask  about that one  that's coming out of my wages  okay what about this one uh there you go  leaving the fashion show  i took that back to the hotel that i  took it from of course you did yeah this  one  there's another one  there's another one  and sometimes you don't even bother to  seal the glass  just a ball  [Applause]